what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the conclusion of ultimate
Invasion and I'm curious to see how you
guys feel about the ending of this don't
forget there is a one shot that comes
out so what this does here is this picks
up with Howard Stark and Doctor Doom
because lest we forget this is not the
traditional Ultimate Universe right the
Ultimate Universe has basically been
destroyed since Secret Wars 2015 as far
as this story is concerned the maker
wanted to recreate it so he just chose
some random Universe out there and then
effectively use what was called the
immortus machine basically a time travel
device in order to jump through the past
and then change things over this
universe's history to make it more to
his own liking and so Howard Stark being
alive Tony Stark is still alive and Dr
Doom is actually Reed Richards he's not
really Victor Von Doom but the whole
idea here is that Howard Stark kind of
hates this reality he doesn't really
like the way the things turned out he
doesn't like the changes that that the
maker has created and so while on the
surface he kind of puts off this
perception that he's duly working on
this immortus machine the reality is
that both he and Dr Doom read whatever
are actively working against the maker
and so that's why when he shows up here
to the maker with this immortus machine
this time travel device that the maker
kind of makes a statement you've built
it the machine that will enable me to do
all the things I've already done a way
to make this world into the wonder that
it is the response of Howard is no I
simply copied it made one of my own a
better version if I do say so myself
because remember there was some point in
time where the maker was attacked and in
fact it's not the initial attack that we
saw right like when all these basically
clones of superheroes from the future
showed up that there was some kind of a
conflict and we'll see it in this comic
where literally half the Maker's head
was blown apart so we effectively forgot
everything right so that's why Howard
Stark is here building this immortus
machine in the first place because
because honestly the maker doesn't
remember the exact changes that he made
and he doesn't remember how to recreate
the immortus machine because it had
effectively been sabotaged and so kind
of the back and forth here while Howard
is talking to the maker the whole time
that's going on Dr Doom is moving from
one location to the next and he's
actually activating these devices that
will essentially shut down the kind of
shield around this city right this giant
Fortress that the maker operates in and
what's funny is the maker says before we
do anything activating this immortus
machine or anything like that we have to
kill the guy from the future who's
sending these clone superheroes back and
taking pot shots now we know that person
is Kang the Conqueror right we know that
from the ending of the last video the
kicker here is the identity of King the
Conqueror and I want to see what you
guys think about the identity of Kang as
we get through this because it's not
Nathaniel Richards it's not the guy who
is traditionally King so what's cool
about this is that as they talk and as
they have this conversation Howard goes
as far as to say like that guy in the
future is a monster you're a monster and
honestly I'm tired of choosing between
which monster is the most desirable
which one is the most acceptable so
basically Doctor Doom activates the
device it shuts down the shield and
that's when Kang makes his move now it's
not as though the groups are working
together don't forget Kang is in the
future always watching the past so he
knew this was going to happen and so
this is just kind of the moment when the
attack gets launched now the reality
here is despite the fact that these are
all cloned superheroes using DNA by and
large they don't really matter here
right they have no real relevance here
outside of the fact that it's just kind
of like a big war that's happening now
for a lot of you guys who are looking at
this and it just doesn't really feel
overly dramatic it makes sense Jonathan
Hickman is the kind of writer where like
he needs room to kind of stretch his
wings right Jonathan Hickman works best
if you give him like four years to write
a comic book story that's how you get
Avengers and New Avengers right you just
get this phenomenal comic book run for
this it's four issues long he had four
months to basically reboot the Marvel
Universe and then we have the Ultimate
Universe one shot that comes out there's
not a whole lot he can do to really
build the characters up and unless
you're overly familiar with the Ultimate
Universe a lot of it's lost on you but
it is still important because this is in
effect the reboot of the Ultimate
Universe so while all these characters
are here the maker sends out his own
forces the children of tomorrow now for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with the children of tomorrow
if you're following our coverage of the
fall of X and we've talked about the
children of the Vault it's effectively
the exact same concept the difference
here is that the children of tomorrow
were created by Reed Richards and the
children of the Vault were not that's
just kind of the big difference between
these two groups but functionally
they're the same right abilities and
technological advancements and so on and
so forth but while this whole fight's
going on Howard Stark starts developing
a kind of plan in his own mind to
essentially take out both the maker and
Kang in one Fell Swoop and so what you
do is you jump to this fight between
Kang and the maker now the funny thing
about this is that in this battle
between the two Kang gives us very very
little information on what his identity
is all he really says is I've waited two
lives for this moment and now the moment
is here but if you look on the chest of
Kane the Conqueror you'll see the exact
same kind of time travel device that was
presented to the maker so that right
there is a kind of clue as to what his
identity is now for everybody else right
for Howard as he's trying to make his
move right literally stealing the time
travel device he's ultimately hit by one
of the forces of Kang and kind of
throwing into this little bit of a
conflict and what we're told is the
power conduit Terminator surge is in one
minute right armed and activated and it
starts counting down so effectively at
the end of this one minute everything
goes sideways and the presumption is
that everything ends now as for the
identity of Kane the Conqueror what ends
up happening is in this fight there's
this point where the Maker's helmet is
smashed right and that's when we see
like half of his head's blown off
although we already knew that and he
talks about how pain clarifies and then
he remembers he remembers who Cain the
Conqueror is that's when we basically
jump to the far future where at some
point after the maker had made these
changes to the universe he had traveled
as far into the future as he possibly
could because what he wanted to know is
whether or not his changes to the time
stream were stable whether or not the
changes to the time stream that he made
would actually stand the test of time or
if he needed to go back and make changes
right say for example there was
something that he didn't account for
something he missed and the changes that
he was hoping would stay permanent ended
up only ever being temporary the issue
is that when he gets here and he comes
into contact with King the Conqueror all
King tells him is like is he says you
are here now as you were always going to
be you are the maker and I've been
waiting for you you are my maker and
then in turn he says and now you witness
my origin and he attacks Reed and blows
off half his head and so that's what
Reid says like I remember I know who you
are and before we actually find out the
identity of Kang Howard shows up and
says so do I and literally with this
kind of time travel device on his chest
he basically activates it and then lets
off this massive amount of energy which
to a degree kind of seems to send time
into disarray we don't know the exact
effect it has all we see is just like
this massive explosion but it's not as
though people are just kind of like
dissipating disappearing right
evaporating it's not like they just
suddenly vanish Into Thin Air and it's
just him by himself right we're like
there's this big explosion and then it
shows the same image but there's nothing
right we don't really know exactly what
this effect is all we know is just a
massive blast of energy and so what you
do is you switch over to latviria which
was the Maker's Castle but now we can
largely assume will become the
headquarters of Doctor Doom and when it
comes to this kind of device right this
actual tried and true immortus engine
basically the one that was real as
opposed to the fake one that was being
carried around by Howard Stark and being
presented to read as the actual immortus
engine even though it wasn't Dr Doom
locks it away in a kind of Vault right
he keeps it hidden away from seemingly
everything Doctor Doom ends up taking it
for himself so that's kind of the
interesting thing here right the entire
immortus engine as it was presented to
read was never real it was seemingly
just a great big huge ruse because the
Hope here was that by taking down the
shield and allowing Kang and his forces
to enter into the city it would give
Howard the ability to destroy them all
at one time it's a genius move it's an
incredibly intelligent move and so what
you do is you pick up with these final
seconds right 14 13 12. Howard Stark
basically wakes up right and he gets out
of his suit he goes over to Kane the
Conqueror he takes off his mask and then
he just kind of holds his head in shame
so there are only really two
possibilities here when it comes to Kane
the Conqueror the hope that I have is
that it would turn out to be Susan storm
because in the Ultimate Universe Susan
storm the wife of Reed she becomes Kang
it was one of the coolest Revelations
from the Ultimate Universe right at
least one of the few cool Revelations
from Ultimate Fantastic Four before John
of the Hickman took over but it was
awesome right it was a really really
cool moment it's obviously not her my
thought is that it's Howard Stark it's
the person Howard Stark becomes he
becomes king to conquer right he becomes
the very monster that he doesn't want to
be on the other hand there is or there
are fan theories at least early theories
so far that is actually Tony Stark that
Tony Stark becomes king the Conqueror I
want to know what you all think right
which one do you think it is and so in
the aftermath of this clock counting
down we end up picking up one week later
and we find out what the countdown
actually meant and we pick up with this
universe's version of the Illuminati
right the ones that we were introduced
to before we'll explain them a little
bit here in a second for those of you
guys who kind of forgot but the idea
behind this is that like the entire city
is shut down the whole thing is shut
down and nobody's getting in and it's
going to be that way for two years now
one of the things to remember about the
nature of the city is that time passes
differently for every one month in the
real world A Thousand Years pass inside
the city so we have no clue what's going
on in there nobody does no one has any
idea Reed Richards Howard Stark Kane the
Conqueror they're not dead or at least
presumably they're not dead but all
three are trapped inside that place so
once this two-year window ends and the
City opens back up what in the world's
gonna come out of it right are they
going to decide to work together are
they going to have killed each other off
well everybody have been killed except
for like one guy Howard or Kang or the
maker we don't have the answer to the
question and so because the Illuminati
is now leaderless the question they have
is what do we do now for those of you
guys who don't really remember the
Illuminati and again as we do with all
our videos at the end of this we'll have
a playlist for you to click on so you
can get caught up on Ultimate Invasion
the idea behind the Illuminati is that
they were kind of a ruse created by the
maker that in looking at society that
make her realize that Humanity can't
function adequately unless it has some
kind of a common enemy right it's like
the same idea as the Matrix right like
if the Keanu Reeves all that kind of
stuff when the Matrix was originally
made first it was a Utopia and then it
became just this place of Horrors and
then the machine Empire realized
Humanity just has to have some measure
of violence death and destruction in its
life in order to believe that the life
that's living is real it's the exact
same thing here but when it came to the
Illuminati they were all working
together that one Kingdom would be quote
unquote the bad guy for a period of time
and all the other kingdoms would team up
against the bad guy and then after that
bad guy was defeated another kingdom
would rise up and become the bad guy and
it was always a way to divert Humanity's
attention and to say that guy over there
is the villain because Humanity cannot
function with a Utopia it's just not in
the nature of people at that point in
time and so all of them working behind
the scenes is kind of like well I mean
what do we do like how do we how do we
make this work and their response is we
basically just split up the entirety of
North America right we split the whole
thing up and we all just rule it like we
literally just take over the entirety of
the world and Rule it as we always did
it's very old man logan-esque right for
those of you guys who remember that
story after all the superheroes on Earth
were killed and Old Man Logan that
basically the villains took over
different parts of the world The
Incredible Hulk ran one section and uh
what was it the Kingpin or Doctor Doom I
think it was ran like another section
The Red Skull ran what was basically New
York right like all the world was
divvied up that's kind of what's
Happening Here and so following that you
basically pick up with Tony Stark
himself meeting with Doctor Doom and
it's a really cool thing because the
exchange is amazing what ended up
happening is Howard had written a letter
to Tony and he asked Doom like my father
gave this to you and the response of
Doom is the world was ending Anthony the
future colliding with the now temporary
kings were being overthrown and
multiversal evils were being undone but
bringing these things to you was my most
important task and so Tony responds in
asking or at least I'm saying the
machine the broken immortus engine which
you and I have already repaired the
secret files you showed me and this a
letter from my father the response of
Doom is while I have some notion of what
could be done with these things the
potential of them he said you would know
what should be done and so the choice is
yours and so Tony Stark kind of sits on
it and he asks him is my father dead and
the only real response he gets from Doom
is variables probabilities the very
character of the man fighting for his
life I'm sorry but I have no way to
definitively answer that question and so
as Tony Stark sits on this for a second
his response is I'm gonna need a suit
and so what he starts doing is basically
building off the Iron Man suit as it was
created by Howard Stark and starts
making adjustments to it it'll need to
handle temporal shear and need some kind
of integrated navigational control and a
weapon it should also be a weapon and so
that's when he ends up building
repulsory now this is where things get
really really cool and this is why I say
that I think it's potentially possible
that Tony Stark became king because when
he finishes the suit and he's asked by
Dr Doom are you going to call yourself
Iron Man after your father the response
of Tony is no right my father was Iron
Man I'm iron lad now why does that
matter because iron lad was the result
in the main Marvel Universe Iron lad was
the result of what happened when Kane
the Conqueror went to his younger self
and tried to force his younger self to
make all the decisions that would need
to be made in order to ensure he became
king the result was that his younger
self rebelled and chose to become a
superhero instead calling himself iron
lad so in effect in the main Marvel
Universe Iron lad is a teenage Kane the
Conqueror before he becomes a villain so
that's why I say that may be what's
going on here right Tony Stark will
eventually become king but for the final
part of this and this is this is one of
the reasons why I love this so much it's
one of the coolest things right remember
one of the things that we did is he went
back he changed things prevented things
from happening for example Thor was
basically removed as the king or at
least prevented from being the king of
Asgard Loki took his place different
things along those lines the letter that
was written to Tony goes exactly like
this right Howard says my dearest
Anthony I am so tired of this world I am
so tired of the people in it of what
they accept and of what they have become
but I know the fault was mine maybe more
than most because of my gifts and the
means that came with them I was so
wrapped up in the good things I was
doing the work and the beauty that work
provided us that I didn't care enough to
notice what was really going on in the
world that I was shaping I know now that
it is a false Fallen world that we paint
as quote unquote good enough but under
its skin we all know it is rotten to the
core and on this reflection almost all
of the things that I have made do
nothing but support the systems that
reduce men and women to pawns and play
things to workers and consumers to
servants and slaves all the things I
have made are tainted with a patina of
evil and he says all of them but one and
that is you if this has found its way to
you then I am gone and I have left you a
world that is no place for the innocent
but only innocent eyes can see it for
what it could be remember Anthony it's
never too late to change the world
around you and so what's going on here
is that Tony Stark and Doctor Doom had
traveled to the Past using the immortus
engine before Reed Richards hit a
initially shown up in this universe and
started changing everything they're
hunting for someone the one person that
no matter what Universe you're in is
always the guy who knows how to lead the
charge is always the guy that can do the
right thing that almost has this
Incorruptible morality that when the
chips are down when it seems like
everything's falling apart he's the guy
that knows how to Rally everyone Tony
Stark and Dr Doom are finding the
ultimate Captain America with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end I'm excited to see what comes out of
this man Ultimate Steve Rogers is back
baited and this guy for those of you
guys who never read the Ultimate
Universe he's dope he's a dick but he is
awesome I love Captain America in the
Ultimate Universe the ultimates are
coming back beta but if you guys need to
get caught up make sure you click the
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later
peace